-Our first guest tonight
is the best-selling author
and Emmy-winning host of
"All in with Chris Hayes,"
which airs weeknights at 8:0
P.M. on MSNBC.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend, Chris Hayes,
everybody.
♪♪♪♪
-Hi.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, you've done a show
without an audience.
-Well --
-But you don't walk out.
Yeah, you don't -- you don't
do a long walk out.
-Over here.
-Hi, buddy.
-How we doing?
-Well, I want to ask
how you're doing.
You did the 12:00 to 2:00 shif
last night.
-Yes, I'm doing the 12:00
to 2:00 shift again tonight.
And then maybe --
-Not a lot happened
between 12:00 to 2:00
last night.
-I'm insulted you would sa
that.
-No, it was nice --
it was nice to have you
providing perspective on it,
but I think for people --
the night before, it seemed like
a lot happened between
12:00 and 2:00.
-Yeah, I mean, we're all -
Look, it's very funny
to look in --
I really love the fact
that these places --
I think it is a great
blow for transparency --
All these places that are
counting the ballots, you know
they have live streams.
And we've had reporters
in there.
At a certain level,
all of us are like,
"Come on, let's hurry up."
And you look at them,
and they're, like...
-Yeah.
-...doing it.
It just -- you know,
it is what it is.
They got a lot to process.
And then these states that
aren't used to this --
Pennsylvania, Nevada
being two examples
where they don't have
a lot of mail-in ballots -
it's just going to take
a little while.
-It does seems like
they have been out in front.
Secretaries of state --
Secretaries of state, right?
-Yeah.
-And attorneys general.
-Attorneys general.
-Yeah.
And election officials.
Where do you think
we are right now?
I mean, so I should clarify.
It's right before 5:00.
You're going to be on TV
a little bit later.
Do you think much will chang
between now and when you're on
-Yes, because Pennsylvania -
Pennsylvania election official
said they might have
the count done today,
which would be...
dispositive, basically.
-Yeah.
-I mean, given
the current margins
in the outstanding ballots
the rate at which they're
coming in,
were Pennsylvania to count
today, I think it's --
it looks like --
we don't know definitively -
that Biden would pull ahead,
perhaps by a margin
along the Michigan level margin,
100,000 votes or plus,
which is sizable.
And that would then be 270
-Right.
-Of sort of states
that we can feel, you know
pretty rock solid about.
-A lot of people have made thi
observation on Twitter,
smarter people than me
who talk about elections.
And we actually alluded to i
before the election
about what happened in 2018,
which is the first
sort of post-op,
which was sort of happening,
I guess, in real time,
was there's no blue wave.
-Yep.
-Just like everybody's saying,
this is very bad.
And that if they had counted
the votes in an opposite order
the narrative would have bee
very different on Tuesday night?
-Oh, that's absolutely true.
I mean, a lot of people
are saying that particularly
with Pennsylvania,
Michigan, and Wisconsin.
Because -- and this was
engineered by
Donald Trump and Republicans
in those states
to prevent them from what'
doing precanvassing,
which is, like, counting ahead
of time these mail-in ballots.
Had they done that first,
it would have been, you know
I think by election night
we would have probably known
that those states were going
to go to Biden.
And if we knew on election night
that the three Midwestern
states had flipped,
giving the 270 necessary,
then it would have been
a very different kind of,
and I feel more definitive
probably, narrative
about what happened.
This -- you know,
post-election narratives
are always dangerous thing
for a bunch of reasons.
One is incomplete data.
Sometimes bad data.
People benchmarking agains
polling expectations
even though
the polls were wrong.
So the thing, there isn't that
"Oh, well, what did this
candidate do wrong
in that race?"
It's, no, the pollster
was wrong...
-Right.
-...that it was a close race
It never was. The candidat
didn't do anything wrong.
They were just not going to wi
that race.
-Right, you're saying that
people who are watching saying
how could they blow
a ten-point polling lead?
-Yeah.
-There's no --
Like, it's not like there --
-There was never
a ten-point polling lead.
-Right, there was never
a ten-point voting lead.
There was a polling projection
which was very different.
-Yes, I think -- I think we no
have enough to know that,
you know, there is something
systemically bad and wrong
with particularly state
and district level polling
And so it gives everyone thi
sense of like,
"Whoa, what happened?"
But if the measurement
was wrong all along --
If the measurement had bee
saying all along, you know
Theresa Greenfield's
going the lose by eight points
in Iowa to Joni Ernst --
-Mm-hmm.
-When she lost by eight points
you say, it was kind of
a plus-eight Republican state.
-Right.
-Looks about
what I would think.
-Yeah, and in the year
leading up to it,
I don't think people would
have been shocked, like,
"Can you believe Joni Erns
is up eight points?"
-No.
-It would have made total sense.
-Now the places where there'
real damage
is in the House districts.
-Right.
-And I think there's
probably some winnable
House districts that were lost
partly because I think --
we'll figure this out, what th
national environment was,
but one big thing you saw
was, you know,
Republican turnout was insane.
-Yeah.
-It was insane on both sides
You know, it's been a catechis
for my life in politics,
I think particularly in certai
circles
on the sort of liberal and lef
that high turnout election
are how Democrats can win.
But you know, there's lots
of people who don't vote
who are also conservatives
-Right.
-And what ends up
happening often
is that if one side motivate
and turns out its people,
the other side does it as well
-Right, because one thing that
will happen is Donald Trum
will end up with far more vote
than he had four years ago
-Yes, numerically more votes
-Right.
-It's going to be
so interesting the see
what that final popular vote
percentage margin is.
-Mm-hmm.
-I mean, one of the things
that's so weird about this
and the electoral college
is we've all watched --
we watch the maps,
and then we watch the states
and then we do the paths
and we press the buttons
and we get the map.
In all the other races
we're watching --
you know, state races,
house races,
someone's winning by
three or four points,
it's like, it looks like they're
going to win that race."
-Yeah.
-And that kind of is what it is.
It was a close but decisiv
victory, four points.
Joe Biden's probably going t
win by that.
-Right.
-Four points, maybe five.
He may win a bigger margin
than Barack Obama's re-electio
in 2012 over Mitt Romney.
I mean, that's pretty striking
The difference being that
Barack Obama's 2012 victor
over Mitt Romney was more
geographically balanced.
And so it got called that nigh
and it was across
a bunch of states
where he had a very clear
electoral advantage.
But in terms of total votes cast
and the total margin,
Biden might actually
beat that spread.
-I want to come back and
talk to you about perception
and optics
of an election like this.
We'll be right back with mor
from Chris Hayes.